when i grew up daytime tv was about like  seasonal cupcake recipes yeah yeah why  are we doing the holocaust at 11 a.m  it's 11 in the morning why are we doing  the holocaust calm down daytime tv is  for people to get into the day we don't  need to be doing genocide  early like relax i heard you put the  call in to get whoopi out of there i did  i because i wanted her to take a timeout  and have a think and i wanted her  replaced with roseanne bring back  roseanne right who is jewish okay so we  get whoopee out okay take a chill pill  read the torah whatever you have to do  go to a few bagel shops and then bring  roseannon who's criminally insane but  jewish and fun so we fixed the show the  real way to fix the show is to destroy  it the view is the it's one of the worst  first of all